[Musica]
io sono microbiologo anch'io per la lode
agricoltura che è cominciata 10.000 anni
fa quando degli uomini hanno piantato
sulle sponde del nilo l'orzo e il grano
e sono nate delle velocemente sono nate
delle piantine a quei tempi
pensavano a una magia è una magia
incredibile poi allo stesso momento è
che sono gli uomini hanno cominciato
allevare gli animali e poi se mi muovo
velocemente arrivare fino al 1700 1800
la seconda grande rivoluzione di cottura
gli uomini cominciavano a fare rotazioni
fa varie culture cominciavano a
concimare il terreno
ok e usare i primi macchinari e infatti
si ha anche pensato che questo proprio
dato lo slancio alla prima rivoluzione
industriale e velocemente arriviamo al
giorno d'oggi l'agricoltura intensiva
siamo al top ingegneria genetica
abbiamo sentito parlare fertilizzanti
pesticidi macchinari eccellenti quindi
rese incredibili ok siamo qui adesso
però dobbiamo andare oltre
come avevamo già sentito nel 2050 questo
grafico qua della fao deve essere
aggiornato saremo quasi 10 miliardi
dobbiamo produrre il 60 per cento più
cibo una chimera incredibile che io
credo non sarà risolta da una da
un'invenzione una scoperta è un tipo
eureka una persona seduta in ufficio
phone esperimento ecco adesso risolto
non sarà diversi tasselli che insieme
magari in modo sinergico ci porteranno a
questo grande traguardo
uno di questi qui la mia chimera uno di
questi
secondo me è la microbiologia io sono un
microbiologo che cos'è la microbiologia
tutto ciò che noi non vediamo col occhio
nudo e microbiologico e adesso forse vi
sorprenderò il 99 per cento della
biodiversità del pianeta e
microbiologico quello che noi vediamo
ogni giorno rappresenta soltanto l'uno
per cento e la micologia fondamentale
per la salute di tutti i know piaciute
della terra
scicli tutti i cicli degli elementi di
che cosa parliamo di batteri di funghi
protozoi arca e piccoli vermetti virus e
nuovi microbiologi siamo pure qualche
volta siamo così da lì la cenerentola
delle scienze perché sono organismi
semplici però abbiamo avuto diversi
l'evoluzione nel nostro mondo e una di
queste le case stiamo vivendo in questo
momento è la genomica noi possiamo
sequenziare il dna velocemente ea costi
bassissimi faccio un piccolo esempio io
faccio ricerca dal 1990 il primo genoma
i batteri hanno un cromosoma
ok non avevamo 23 paia un cromosoma
anche piccolo il primo battello è stato
sequenziato nel 1995 96 il bacillus
subtilis ed è stato sequenziato con un
progetto europeo è costato più di un
miliardo delle vecchie lire dove 40 e
laboratori in giro per l'europa hanno
ricevuto un pezzettino del genoma e lo
hanno sequenziato manualmente e poi è
stato assemblato due o tre anni di
lavoro l'anno scorso ha avuto una
studentessa di tesi magistra il mio
laboratorio e parte del suo progetto
parte di hera sequenziare 20 genomi di
un'altra specifica terra che è il 50 per
cento più il genoma 50 per cento più
grande del bacillus subtilis 1.500 euro
qualche settimana 25 anni
quindi questa capacità di sequenziare il
dna in modo così potente ci permette
adesso noi microbiologi di fare una cosa
che non potevamo per noi era era
fantascienza per me quindici vent'anni
fa di andare nelle zone del mondo della
terra prendere tutto il dna purificare
tutto dina in quella zona li e
sequenziare tutto quindi facciamo una
fotografia di tutta la mia felicità
presente in un in un ambiente tutti i
componenti i microblog di quell ambiente
si chiama microbioma una parola che non
esisteva qualche anno fa è stata coniata
recentemente questo succede spesso nella
scienza nuove tecniche nuove scoperte
nuove innovazioni
il microbioma ce ne sono tanti ci sono
tanti scienziati che studiano questo
microbioma ci siamo accorti quanto
complesso è la maggior parte dei
microrganismi che abbiamo in giro in
giro e nel pianeta non li possiamo
crescere in laboratorio è per questo che
questa tecnologia ci permette di queste
fotografie ci dicono delle cose che
prima erano veramente impossibile questa
ecco appunto importante purtroppo la
grande maggioranza dei microrganismi non
li possiamo portare laboratorio
crescerli tanti scienziati in giro per
il mondo studiano diversi micro biomi
noi abbiamo del suolo della pianta
dell'animale perché la mitologia
dappertutto quello sicuramente più
sudato il microblog microbioma dell'uomo
noi uomini abbiamo un trilione di
cellule nostre umane
abbiamo 10 trilioni di microrganismi che
vivono insieme a noi ogni giorno non
esiste uomo sulla terra che non ha
questo se non avessimo questi meccanismi
moriamo i pochi giorni infatti quando vi
vedo mi sembra il peso come come dei
microrganismi non come come degli uomini
il punto il punto focale sua è
l'intestino
ci sono due chilogrammi di microrganismi
nell'intestino che comunità molto
complesse che ci che è considerato un
organo esterno fa delle cose fondi
vitali per noi ci dà le vitamine ci
aiuta a digerire cibo ci induce sistema
immunitario cercare una barriera contro
i patogeni che ci vogliono che vogliono
ucciderlo se cellule per procurarsi cibo
il microbioma in tutti questi ambienti è
così importante che per celebrarlo
qualche anno fa è stato istituito il
world macro bayonne dei 27 giugno
proprio per ricordarci l'importanza di
preservare questa questi microbioma ca
di celebrare la sua importanza
io mi interesso del microbioma dell'app
delle piante suolo piante e questa foto
vi fa vedere
numeri importanti un grammo di suolo
contiene 100 milioni di microrganismi in
quel cucchiaino che vedete lì ci sono
più microorganismi che uomini sulla
terra il suolo è vivo da solo nasce
tutto nasce la catena alimentare
se noi abbiamo un suolo se noi prendiamo
il suolo e lo portiamo a temperature
altissime uccidiamo tutta la mitologia
le piante crescono malissimo e i cicli
di non avvengono più quindi quando
vedete il suolo è la vita
ok ed acquisto d'acquisto da questa
microbiologia quando noi
piantiamo i nostro il nostro cibo che le
nostre piante che poi noi mangiamo la
pianta a questo che poi fra l'altro il
suolo è il microbioma ad oggi più
diverso che c'è in me troviamo nel suolo
quindi la pianta si trova questa
fantastica micro biodiversità
microbiologica e lava reclutare ci sono
delle comunicazioni che stiamo studiando
affascinanti di capire come la pianta la
pianta recluta vuole vuole crearsi un
microbioma forte utile da utile sicuro
vitale per lui quindi molto forte e la
terra più vicino alla radice non andiamo
oltre 2 o 3 mm si chiama riso sfera e
anche anche la pianta come l'uomo a
diversi microbioma delle foglie ma il
microbioma e di quella zona è il più
importante è l'intestino della pianta è
il perfetto parallelismo quindi infatti
la biodiversità nella risolverà e 10
volte piu alta della biodiversità
biologica del suolo
figuriamoci quindi questo reclutamento
questa creazione microbioma nelle piante
è fondamentale ok quindi programmi di
recluta comunicazione alimentare
microbioma le piante e sudano dalle loro
radici il 15 per cento del carbonio
delle di quello che producono con la
fotosintesi e non lo fanno perché perché
la pianta è costruita male lo fanno
proprio per alimentare il proprio
microbioma
e come l'intestino il microbioma è
importante per la crescita ci sono
microrganismi che producono ormoni delle
piante che loro non servono a niente lo
fanno per per dare qualcosa alla pianta
in cambio a questa nicchia dove loro
possono vivere bene aiutano a qui
aiutano la pianta acquisire nutrienti
fosfato ferro ferro nutrienti che la
piazza non ha accesso inducono il
sistema immunitario
abbiamo sentito parlare di strass e
mentali in futuro dovremo crescere il
nostro cibo in terre marginali troppo
calde molto salate dove manca acqua e
questo microbioma o può aiutare le
piante a crescere in questi ambienti e
anche come nel nostro intestino
ci sono dei patogeni che vogliono
attaccare le piante e tanti non tutti ma
tanti attaccano le radici entrano dalle
radici
quindi questo che io io mi io sto
studiando e questo che è una frontiera
che noi vogliamo capire e questa è una
foto del mio laboratorio quello che noi
facciamo andiamo in questa in queste
zone delle piante prendiamo sequenzia mo
tutto e tramite dei software creiamo dei
network questo è un network di un
microbioma della goody una risorsa del
riso e ogni puntino rappresenta un
microorganismo e se il micro che è la
grandezza del puntino rappresenta
l'abbondanza quanto ce ne dico il
microrganismo è la posizione di quel
rigorismo è molto importante perché se
nel centro e in un punto nodale e noi la
togliamo vi potete immaginare che
network comincia a essere instabile
debole mentre magari quelli più
periferia lì sono forse non meno
importanti e questo questo microbioma si
è voluto per milioni di anni
insieme alle piante comunica fra loro è
un organismo multicellulare che lavora
in concerto in sincronia quindi questo è
questo quello che io faccio e lo
facciamo lo faccio in tutto il mondo io
lavoro in un centro iternazionale che
guardiamo molto in paesi vedi sviluppo
in certi paesi e di sviluppo
l'agricoltura rappresenta più del 30 per
cento del gdp
e quello che noi facciamo andiamo là
fuori mi interesso di riso più che al
riso ma anche di olivo di vite e andiamo
a zone geografiche dove dove raccogliamo
riso sfere di piante malate o stressate
e nello stile e della stessa specie di
pianta ma molto vicino geograficamente
anche magari a 40 metri sono bene stanno
bene sono sane sono forti e quello che
noi pensiamo e che queste due piante
hanno una una recluta del microbioma
diversa e microbioma della pianta sana
resistente ai patogeni resistenti agli
stress e forte è quello migliore e se
noi li paragoniamo la pianta malata e
stand tante verso le piante forti e
facciamo dei paragoni possiamo magari
come creare creiamo questi network e
possiamo capire quali microrganismi sono
fondamentali per il microbioma di quella
del riso da quella specie in quella zona
e dopo possiamo isolare questi
microrganismi cresce in laboratorio non
li modifichiamo geneticamente e li diamo
l'agricoltore facciamo dei prodotti dei
probiotici in modo che la pianta il seme
che l'agricoltore pianta può essere già
parte già vantaggiato parte già con i
key stone element come noi keystone mike
organismo questa nelle quali i
meccanismi principali nodali del suo
microbioma questo mondo è questa questa
microbiologia a questo
si sta dando molto interesse vi dico che
io collaboro anche con delle aziende
nella ricerca
sapete che i finanziamenti alla ricerca
noi soffriamo molto specialmente chi fa
ricerca nei paesi come e sviluppate come
il nostro anche in nord america in agro
alimentare i finanziamenti sono sono
sono pochi perché la maggior parte più
del 90 per cento va nella ricerca
biomedica a noi ci piace finanziare
ricerca che abbiamo un ritorno diretto
ed è giusto che malattie genetiche
malattie cardiovascolari il cancro ed è
giusto però forse stiamo trascurando la
ricerca nelle nelle nelle materie
agroalimentari infatti un recente studio
negli stati uniti ha dimostrato che i
dottorati di ricerca che il primo è chi
vuole fare ricerca come bisogna
cominciare con un dato di un dottorato
di ricerca fare il dottorato di ricerca
i dottorati di ricerca nel settore
biomedico negli ultimi 15 anni hanno
avuto né un aumento quasi esponenziale
mentre i dottorati cerca né nelle
materie agroalimentari nelle ricerca
sulle piante mentre sono rimasti flat
piatti per tornare a quel che dicevo
prima tante start up sono molto
interessate a usa a usare questa
informazione microbioma per fare dei
prodotti per l'agricoltura come come
come vi faccio vedere qui come dare dare
dei semi all'agricoltore che già
ricoperti di questi keystone bakhti
christie's keystone michael organismo
questi micro rismi nodali metterli nel
suolo arricchirli rivitalizzare il suolo
o anche darle un po più avanti
quindi l'idea è questa
e io con queste start up stiamo facendo
stiamo cercando di fare di andare in
questa direzione qua per un'agricoltura
molto più sostenibile e per tornare alla
chimera e concludere questo secondo
questo come dicevo non vi sto dicendo
assolutamente che studiamo il microbioma
capiamo microbioma facciamo dei dei
prodotti eccezionali e portiamo 60 per
cento no è uno dei è un tassello secondo
me è un tassello molto importante
che insieme ad altri tasselli dobbiamo
lavorare per arrivare a questo 60 per
cento
perché se no può darsi che la mancanza
di già oggi sappiamo che ci sono tanta
gente che soffre meno magari per motivi
anche diversi ma questo questo 60 per
cento
la microgramma è sicuramente secondo me
un tassello fondamentale grazie tanto
[Applauso]
[Musica]